Free Speech dead at the Edinburgh Fringe
which is all about free speech and
comedy what happened what you're seeing
in comedy is fascinating because it's
not the Edinburgh Fringe Festival it's
the Edinburgh Conformity festival and
what it means is if you stray Beyond
certain parameters of what is deemed
acceptable and unacceptable you will be
canceled and what is really interesting
is you look at that lineup then there
was one comedian on that lineup who is a
traditional conspiracy theorist he
believes in quite far out conspiracies
but that's great that's his right no one
no one has a problem with that no one
has a problem with the fact that he's a
little bit Tonto yet Graeme comes along
and says you know what maybe a woman
can't have a 12 inch penis out you go
mate the door's over there son so but
this is
a thing because this is all about
actually all Graham did was talk about
women's rights and you know this is
something that amazing comedians like
Ricky Gervais Ricky Gervais makes jokes
about you know women's rights and and
the transphobic debate but his selling
out stadiums around the world so why do
we have a problem with someone like
Graham
a small a small venue let's be honest in
Edinburgh because the reality is is
Ricky is so big that he's essentially
uncancelable same with Dave Chappelle
when you get to a certain level of
success and notoriety and fame and you
can generate millions and millions of
dollars for companies like Netflix or
Amazon and you can fill out stadiums
around the world nobody's going to want
to cancel you because everybody's making
a very pretty penny off it but someone
like Graham who can't come on that type
of Revenue all of a sudden he becomes
fair game for this type of behavior yeah
and meanwhile we've got Frankie ball
making jokes about rape and and Graham
was also banned from Twitter at one
point wasn't he who let the Taliban have
an account yeah absolutely but we all
know that grammar is far more
problematic views in the Taliban well
yeah of course I mean yeah I mean you
have to say as well the Taliban are
pretty gender critical they can be yes I
don't have a very high opinion to women
unlike Graham yes who's actually just
supports women I don't see but let's
talk balls shall we yes as in footballs
as in the tiny weenie I think it's for
the World Cup going on tomorrow morning